Imperial Grand Admiral chis Warrior
bluest man in the Galaxy Thon is known
as many things here's the question
though who is he really although Thon
was the main antagonist of Star Wars
Rebels for two of its Four Seasons
precious little was revealed in the show
about his Origins however the Star Wars
thraw novels plug the Gap nicely
revealing much about thon's people the
chis the chis are a race living in the
unknown regions an area made remote by
Cosmic obstacles such as black holes
keeping them largely hidden from
Outsiders however this isolation acts as
a double-edged sword as the people of
the unknown regions lack access to
technologies that might have allowed
them to Traverse the dangers of their
region of space fortunately for the chis
some of their young hold a strong
connection to the force giving them the
ability to chart safe courses through
the unknown regions however the chis
rarely if ever venture out of their home
area this is because they are governed
by the ruling body known as the chis
ascendancy which enex policies of
secrecy to prevent the species Discovery
though thron's birth name was kivu Nuru
his name changed to Mithra Nuru Odo as a
sign of respect during his successful
military career the name Thon comes from
this a shorthand name that combines his
new family name with his given name the
chests were not alone in the unknown
regions however their biggest threat is
an alien race called the grisk known for
their warlike nature and mind control
abilities the grisk are ruled by a
hegemony very similar to the Galactic
Empire in makeup with the biggest
similarity between the two governments
being a desire to expand their influence
at any cost in studying the grisk and
their tactics Thon inadvertently made
himself an invaluable asset for
Palpatine's Empire but the battle
against the grisk wasn't without its own
complications while the Empire ruled the
Galaxy for a relatively brief period of
time the grisk were established early
enough that they were able to monitor
the Clone Clone Wars indicating their
Ambitions had been planned out for some
time but while the Gris certainly had
designs to expand their empire they had
to go through the chis to realize their
goals the chis ascendancy realized this
and sought allies to fight the grisk a
task eventually given to Captain Thon
thron's loyalty to the chis stands above
all else so how and why did he come to
serve the Empire the why is surprisingly
simple the chis ascendancy needed to
determine whether the Empire could help
them defeat the grisk hemony so they
ordered Thon to join the Imperial
military they wanted him to either
convince the Empire to stand with the
chis against the grisk or manipulate
events such that the grisk would attack
the Empire first giving the chis more
time to prepare the how is a bit more
complicated to help convince the Empire
he has nowhere else to go thron fakes
his Exile from the chis then he chooses
a world he knows the Empire will
eventually explore and waits once the
Empire comes to the planet he slowly and
methodically picks off their scouting
party eventually forcing their Retreat
Thon takes this opportunity to sneak
aboard an imperial ship and allow
himself to be captured once on board he
tells his story to the ranking officers
impressed with his tactical skills they
bring him before Emperor
Palpatine thraw gains favor with the
emperor on the basis of his history with
Anakin Skywalker whom he had met during
the Clone Wars although Thon doesn't
receive any guarantees Palpatine does
agree to consider helping the chis if
Thon serves the Empire Faithfully
although Thon ultimately swears
allegiance to the Empire and Palpatine
the effort he makes to gain the
emperor's trust proves that his loyalty
to the chis remained
undimmed while thron holds up his end of
the deal to serve the Empire Faithfully
his methods put him at odds with some
high-ranking Imperial officials in order
to protect himself from the threat of a
court Marshal he attends several parties
held by powerful members of the Empire
at one such party Thon comes into
contact with arenda price an ambitious
govern government employee although
nothing significant occurred in their
first meeting their connection would
prove to be mutually beneficial when
price is blackmailed by a rival thraw
gives her valuable advice to turn the
tables this advice allows her to thwart
her blackmailer and become governor of
the loal sector sometime later price and
thron work together on a military
campaign to crush a small group of
rebels on the planet baton price is
responsible for a large number of
Civilian casualties during the uprising
which outrages thraw he initially plans
on reporting Price's misdeeds to the
Imperial Security Bureau but is
convinced otherwise when price offers to
get thrawn promoted to Grand Admiral a
ranking Thon understandably covets as it
would allow him to better proceed with
his primary mission for the chis however
Price's offer comes with a catch she
will only secure his promotion if Thon
brought his Fleet to the lothal system
to deal with the rebel cell known as
Phoenix Squadron thron begins his war
against Phoenix Squadron almost
immediately after receiving his
promotion to Grand Admiral although he
finds an opportunity to destroy the
Rebel Ship ghost during a raid at ream
station thraw allows the ship to go free
in order to reel in a much larger prize
the location of Phoenix squadron's
hidden base in order to better
understand how the rebels operated thron
spends much of his time analyzing their
past and their strategies thron's almost
religious study of all things Phoenix
Squadron pays big dividends when he
recognizes some distinctive artwork on
the helmet of a supposed bount bount
Hunter captured by imperial agent Callis
after deducing the Bounty Hunter is in
fact Ezra Bridger thron realizes callus
was a double agent he allows him to
continue operating as one until he makes
his next transmission thron then tracks
the transmission to the planet of adelon
and launches an allout assault defeating
and scattering the rebels his efforts to
capture them are thwarted however by a
creature known as the bendu after being
shot down thron's defeat is foretold by
the bendu I see your defeat like many
arms surrounding you in a cold Embrace
although Thon is Victorious over Phoenix
Squadron in the short term the bendo's
words eventually come back to haunt him
after defeating the Rebels on adalon
Thon is ordered by Palpatine to
accompany Darth Vader to investigate a
disturbance in the force on Batu the
same planet on which thraw and Skywalker
had first met the two locate and capture
a band of mysterious aliens who turn out
to be grisk agents thrawn and Vader lead
an assault on the grisk base and after
securing Victory locate the source of
the disturbance Palpatine had felt for
sensitive chis children whom the grisk
had captured in order to make them serve
as Navigators although Vader wants the
children eliminated thron assures him
that the force sensitive chis would pose
no threat since their connection to the
force grows weaker when they reach
adulthood after rooting out the
remaining grisk and rescuing more chis
children thraw returns them to the
ascendant seat however he also learns
that the chis are heading toward a civil
war with the grisk backing one of the
chess factions Thon then reasons that
since the grisk were attempting to
capture Navigators it was likely that
they were preparing to eliminate the
chis so they could wage war on the
Empire while thron continues to serve
the empire in the aftermath of this
incident these latest discoveries only
Harden thon's dedication to the chis
cause in order to Curry favor with
Palpatine and convince him to help the
chis against the grisk thron decides to
develop a weapon that could ensure the
empire stability for years to come he
chooses to improve the standard TIE
fighter by giving it more Firepower a
hyperdrive and a deflector Shield the
Rebel Alliance sees this new TIE fighter
dubbed the tie Defender as a grave
threat since none of their X-Wing craft
have the Firepower to deal with its
enhanced capabilities as a result the
rebels authorize a raid on loal where
the nuts and bolts of the project are
located the attack is an object failure
however with nearly every rebel pilot
killed and their leader Hera sindula
captured with his Factory safe thraw is
informed of a new threat to his tie
Defender project project Stardust
otherwise known as the Death Star if
construction of the defender is to
continue you must make your case
directly to the emperor himself
concerned about the Empire's dedication
to this hugely expensive project thron
decides to meet with Palpatine
personally on corusant unfortunately
thron's journey to meet with Palpatine
proves to be the end of his project as
Governor price blows up all of the fuel
for the tie defenders in a successful
attempt to kill the Jedi Kanan jerus the
end of the tie Defender project holds
major implications for the Galaxy as it
Spurs Palpatine to throw his support
behind project Stardust it is also a
massive blow for thraw as his Avenue of
gaining favor with the emperor is closed
off following the failure of the tide
Defender project thraw is ordered by the
emperor to crush the Rebellion on loal
and capture the young Jedi Ezra Bridger
thrawn eager to regain favor with the
emperor to help save his people brings
the might of the seventh fleet to Bear
threatening to blow up the capital city
unless the Jedi surrenders after
ensuring Ezra is in the hands of the
emperor thron returns to the bridge of
his capital ship the Chimera and orders
the fleet to bombard the planet the
shelling of the capital does nothing
however as the Rebels on the ground
managed to raise a planetary defense
shield in time although Thon sends his
bodyguard Rook to shut down the
planetary Shield the rebels managed to
fight off the Imperial forces and ensure
The Shield's functionality upon hearing
of rook's death Ezra enters the bridge
and demands thon's surrender although
thraw was still planning on continuing
the fight he is forestalled by the
arrival of pergal large space whales
that are capable of light speed the
Perle completely decimate the entirety
of thron's Fleet with one smashing into
the bridge of the Chimera and wrapping
its tendrils around thron fulfilling the
bendo's vision of the grand Admiral's
defeat the Perle then jumped to light
speed flinging both Ezra and Thon to an
unknown destination in space and
completely destroying any hope thron had
of using the Empire to save his people
um was that the plan in 1991 author
Timothy Zan wrote heir to the Empire
this novel which was later adapted into
a comic series chronicled The Adventures
of Luke Skywalker Leia Orana Han Solo
and their merry band of rebels following
the events of Return of the Jedi set
approximately 5 years later Grand
Admiral thraw is in introduced as the
next in line to restart the Galactic
Empire and crush the new Republic the
story continues with the novel's dark
force rising and the last command in
which thron's plans are thwarted by Luke
and his allies a few years later the
author wrote two more novels to follow
up his Trilogy this is known as the hand
of thron duology and that was only the
beginning the grand Admiral would return
to play the role of recurring antagonist
throughout the extended Universe for
decades the original thron trilogy
served as the launching point for the
greater Star Wars expanded universe but
when Disney purchased Lucas film in 2012
everything changed thraw like many other
characters and stories was written out
of continuity by the house of mouse with
Zan's acclaimed Trilogy being rebranded
under the Legends Banner when thraw was
eventually reintroduced into the
continuity Lucas film made a few
significant changes to the character for
starters unlike in the air to the Empire
storyline the Disney versions of Thon
and Luke never encounter one another
instead Ahsoka Tano and Ezra Bridger
service thon's main adversaries with
Luke off elsewhere reestablishing the
Fallen Jedi Order selling over 15
million copies Zan's Trilogy was so
successful that his work on air to the
Empire is credited by some with saving
the Star Wars franchise at a time when
new adventures were scarce following the
original theatrical release of Return of
the Jedi and a few other 80s projects
that we really don't need to talk about
Star Wars content had stalled by the
early '90s George Lucas had yet to
develop the prequel trilogy so Zan's
work single-handedly carried the
franchise opening the door for more
expanded universe stories though Lucas
didn't consider them Canon he
nevertheless took plot beats characters
and locations from the EU and added them
to his new films no doubt thon's
popularity among Star Wars fans was a
reason why Zan's Trilogy was so
successful for many years the heir to
the Empire Trilogy was the closest thing
to a direct Star Wars sequel Trilogy
that fans seemed likely to witness as
Lucas largely moved on from the
franchise from the mid 80s to the turn
of the century thron's reappearances in
various novels games and comics were
quite welcome among fans before Disney
swooped in and took over it also
explains why the character survived the
house of Mouse's Purge of the greater
extended Universe he was too important
to fans to be erased entirely perhaps
understandably some fans still hold out
hope that other characters from this era
could one day return as well no one's
ever really gone Grand Admiral thraw had
the pleasure of meeting both both Anakin
Skywalker and Darth Vader during very
different phases of the former Jedi's
life the 2018 novel thraw alliances
revolves around the brief partnership
between the Sith Lord and the warlord as
they work together to investigate the
force disturbance on Batu but alliances
doesn't just cover this partnership
between Thon and Vader it also flashes
back to the Clone Wars when thraw and
the young Skywalker worked together to
save Padme amadala during this time
thron deduces that Anakin is a Jedi
although Anakin believes role as a Jedi
was obvious given the color of his
lightsaber Thon explains his hesitation
he tells Anakin our myths of the
Republic speak of two groups of beings
with such Powers the Jedi and the Sith
but the Sith are reputed to be clever
and capable Warriors as it turns out
Anakin's numerous mistakes in combat
allowed thron to correctly identify him
as a Jedi years later Emperor Palpatine
tells Thon of Skywalker's death
following the Clone Wars despite this
lie the chis double agent quickly
deduces that Lord V and the former
General Skywalker are one and the same
as one of the only people in the galaxy
to uncover this safeguarded information
Thon keeps it to himself smart move Thon
since the chips are so far removed from
the known Galaxy they have little to no
knowledge of society in the Republic
nevertheless the force still extends
into the unknown regions even if the
people who reside there don't actually
know what it is for the chis people four
sensitive children may not have the same
giftings as other races do but they
still obtain a premonition ability which
they call third sight because of their
ability to peer into the future children
with third sight are conscripted to
become space fairing Navigators since
the chis don't use traditional
technological navigation thon's older
sister kardok otherwise known as vka was
one of these four sensitive children and
was taken when thraw was just a boy as
an adult like many chis children with
third site vka lost her precognitive
abilities and instead worked as an
instructor for future Navigators despite
being siblings when confronted by the
chance to finally meet her long-lost
brother Vera now known as bka after her
marriage weeps believing that there is
no point since her memories of thron
have long faded tragically despite
having once believed that one day he
might use his resources to find her Thon
never reunites with his sister
eventually he comes to respect her
wishes for anonymity and moves on the
events of the Star Wars Rebels finale in
which Ezra Bridger and thrawn are thrown
into the unknown are set in the the same
year as the original Star Wars film I
find your lack of faith disturbing in
that movie The Empire loses Grand Moff
Tarkin and the first death star at the
hands of Luke Skywalker and the Rebel
Alliance after these two enormous
defeats the emperor tasks Darth Vader
with personally overseeing the
destruction of the rebels in Star Wars
number eight which is set after Vader's
Showdown with Luke on Cloud City
Palpatine claims that thraw or Tarkin
would have been perfect for this job and
laments that both are gone though the
task delays the Sith Lord's search for
his long-lost son Vader deems it
necessary for the health of the empire
in thron's absence Darth Vader continues
to hunt down the rebels during the
so-called War of the bounty hunters he
comes close to capturing Han Solo and a
number of his allies But ultimately
failed had thron still been around
however these events might not have gone
as well for Luke and his friends and
it's entirely possible that Luke may
have been captured prior to his
surrender in Return of the ey likewise
Vader's position overseeing construction
of the second death star may have been
held by someone else had thrawn or
Tarkin survived meaning his turn back to
the light may never have occurred
although Thon is often seen as a
ruthless leader willing to do whatever
it takes for the sake of his Ambitions
this couldn't be further from the truth
from his youth into his Imperial career
thron always believes that every life
holds some sort of value though he has
no problem eliminating his enemies he
sees the death deaths of innocent
civilians as senseless and unnecessary
in the novel Thon a sentenc see great or
good he says all lives are important and
I resist the thought of standing by and
watching 200 possibly needless deaths
this was especially true of thron when
he served in the chis military but it
generally carries over to his time with
the Empire as well generally speaking
thron also shows deep respect for his
enemies but this only goes so far in
Star Wars Rebels thron unleashes his
full fury on the lothal system near the
end of his time there after his
increasingly futile attempts to put the
Insurgency down he fires on the people
of capital city until Ezra Bridger
surrenders himself to the Empire it's
worth noting that these actions come
about due to intense pressure from
Emperor Palpatine who hopes to turn Ezra
to the dark side but thron is certainly
still the man in charge during the
bombardment had thron been given more
time however he may have come up with an
alternative solution that didn't
threaten the lives of those below an
interesting shade to the thron character
is the grand Admiral's love or at least
appreciation of traditional art and
music believing the Arts to be a window
into the history and culture of
different people groups thron sees it as
a valuable tool to be used to better
understand his allies and opponents my
apologies Captain slaven I forgot not
everyone is able to appreciate art as I
do in the Zan novel Thon ascendancy
lesser evil a younger Thon is shown
analyzing hundreds of thousands of
different pieces of artwork that belong
to his adoptive family many of which
were created by Anonymous artists he
even manages to connect a series of
seemingly unrelated works together based
solely on style and technique eventually
discovering the artist's identity
likewise in Rebels Thon is shown to have
amassed an impressive collection of
artwork that all point to the crew of
the ghost which includes Ezra Bridger
Sabine Ren and haris syndulla in his
time studying their work he comes to
better understand and his enemies and
uses this knowledge of their goals and
ideals to overpower them across his
various media appearances this
appreciation for the Arts has remained a
strong consistent character trait for
the chis warlord though thraw isn't much
of an artist himself his knowledge and
understanding of technique and structure
have proven invaluable to his military
campaign and it's very possible that
we'll see more of the grand Admiral's
cultural side in future Star Wars
projects though there are any number of
military leaders who could have been the
basis for Grand Admiral Thon Zan
revealed the exact source of his
inspiration in a letter written in 2002
he wrote thron isn't based on any one
historical person in particular but is
more of a composite of the best and
brightest military Geniuses that have
ever lived on zon's list Hannibal
Alexander the Great Robert E Lee and
Irwin raml Zan continued to explain
thron's characterization by emphasizing
that he unlike many real life military
leaders genuinely cares about those
under his command the lives of his
officers matter to him and he has no
desire to see any of them Gunn down for
no reason since thraw was supposed to be
a different sort of villain than Darth
Vader who ruled his underlings by fear
he was made into a tactical genius a man
who would be so respected by his men
that they would follow him anywhere but
zhan wasn't only inspired by the
historical leaders of old to create
thraw he was also inspired by popular
fictional characters including a few who
wouldn't have been all that fond of the
grand Admiral's Allegiance es for
example Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's famous
detective Sherlock Holmes was a clear
template for thon's ability to piece
together a mystery Elementary my dear
Watson purely Elementary of course
although Holmes uses his exceptional
mind to help others Thon uses it to
advance the goals of the Empire which is
a little less noble to say the least
despite being the Beloved antagonist of
the most well-received Star Wars novels
the editors at Marvel Comics reportedly
had no initial interest in including the
infamous Grand Admiral and the their
ongoing Star Wars titles according to
former Marvel assistant editor Heather
antos who took to Twitter to show her
support for thon's reintroduction into
the franchise a very important tier up
at Marvel told her the blue guy no one
cares about him of course it was only a
few years later that thron would get his
own comic series in support of his debut
on Rebels clearly someone had a change
of heart and ever since his successful
return Thon has become a recurring
character throughout the greater Star
Wars Universe be it the different comic
books various thraw themed novels or his
presence in the live action shows it's
clear that Thon is here to stay and of
course with the announcement of Dave
filoni's upcoming movie which is set to
round off these stories begun by the
Mandalorian the book of Boba Fett and
Asoka there's also a lot to look forward
to as thron expands his grasp over the
Star Wars franchise in addition to the
thron trilogy that Timothy Zan penned in
the early '90s the author found the
chance to tackle the character on a
number of occasions afterward though Zan
wrote various sequel stories featuring
thron that took place after the last
command he also took on a number of
novels set in the Disney continuity the
first of the new thraw Trilogy was Star
Wars thraw which was followed up by
thraw alliances and thraw treason these
projects allowed the characters Creator
to reintroduce him to Star Wars as the
protagonist of his own story and it
didn't end there though Zan had
reinvented thron helping transition him
from Legends into Canon he had more sto
stories to tell concerning the grand
Admiral in 2020 another thron based
novel titled thron ascendency chaos
Rising was published by zon this one
exploring the character's history with
his people the chis and the Rivalry with
the grisk known as the Thon ascendancy
Trilogy Zan continued thron's pre- Clone
Wars story with greater good in 2021 and
lesser Evil later that year rounding out
his overhaul of the character's past and
forever changing the way fans saw the
chis Legend knowing that Zan is involved
in future thron stories should give Star
Wars loyalists hope that however the
grand Admiral is adapted next his
creator won't be far
behind